nous avons invité patrick fiori valérie
damidot jean baptiste
[Musique]
qui ont accepté le célébrer avec moi les
quatre fois vingt ans de michel drucker
[Musique]
bonsoir lisa êtes un peu surprise un
petit peu oui on m'a laissé entendre que
vous étiez une personne choquée
et personne ne vient m'aider
on fait attention ne pas les faire
tomber c'est parfois ça arrive
malheureusement attention aux plats
voilà en direct ça va faire du monde
foot quand même heureusement corbeau le
ballotin sur un arbre paumé tenait entre
ses crocs 1 comme ac phr de gomme renard
le combinard qui n'avaient pas croquer
radina en loucedé pour lui faire de
l'est ce tome bon j'avoue remet mon pote
je n'avais pas gaffer que tu étais 6 bat
taissy bien balancé cité chicotte son
kif kif avec ta bouillotte tu es le plus
giron des mecs tondu loin qu'est je ne
suis pas simplement en train d'éclater
les français j'étais à courchevel il ya
deux choses que m'ont frappé
d'abord
ces jaloux
et à ses admirateurs parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de pays qui pensent qu'ils sont
les meilleurs pilotes au monde mais vous
vous avez et vous avez le sud de la
france et vous pouvez aussi aller skier
il n'y a aucune raison pour un français
ne quittez la le corbeau répondit
vieille cloche à taper frometon avec ses
asti bloch
moralité sa fille
moralité chacun dans son coin qui veut
rester peinard doit boucler son clapet
devant les combinards
pour la star nabila et ses 7 millions
300 mille abonnés
les annonceurs payent jusqu'à 10000
euros pour une courte vidéo
jessica ti venin 6 million deux cent
mille abonnés c'est 7000 euros
mais là jasmin et ses trois millions
trois cent mille abonnés coûte jusqu'à
3000 euros la fortune de la reine quand
on pense à combien elle vaut et estime
est à peu près 400 millions d'euros la
fortune privée de la reine est bien sûr
une accumulation de fortune par séance
est
ensuite la reine n'a pas payé d'impôt
pendant 40 ans ce qui lui a permis de se
constituer un beau pactole ce qu'elle on
n'a pas d'idée d'ailleurs quelle part
revient à magali berda et à son agence
nous nous sommes procuré ce document
auprès d'un ancien employé sur cette
opération shauna events a pris une
commission de 20 %
c'est parfois beaucoup plus selon
certains influenceurs contacté
en 2020 lagence de magali berda a
déclaré 3 millions d'euros de bénéfices
est-ce que je vais pas envie qu'on
arrête tout ce jeu capitaliste
matérialiste
et 4 et qu'on fasse d'amour tous tout nu
allez on s'en fout
chantal oui la série dans une telle
situation si quelqu'un vient embêter
parce que sa bible de partout là elle me
dit un ami
vous confirmez les amis elle capable de
tout
mais c'est vrai si sa bible de partout
ça touche des plus stériles et
maintenant
qu'elle est douée tôt ajouté à la sueur
pour pouvoir passer l'aspirateur dans
les coins barras et
hadrons dominique c'est pour avoir le
dessus ça c'est quoi le [ __ ] est le
petit tuyau
ses longues ou d'aspirateurs là on
ajoute au tuyau d'aspirateur pour
nettoyer des ti coin ça s'appelle un
[ __ ] oui ma chaîne sport et ben faut
vous mettre en ménage il faut deux
mètres [ __ ] bah ouais ben ça alors
figurez vous que je le fais moi isabeau
de la tour qui vante les mérites d'un
site de paris sportifs avec un peu trop
d'enthousiasmé le pari en fait ça c'est
génial parce que du coup vous n'avez
rien à faire strictement rien affirmer
qu'il n'ya rien à perdre pour un site de
paris c'est illégal
on aurait pu continuer comme ça
longtemps mais on a voulu en parler à
magali berda et ça ne lui a pas plu qui
ad c'est kim kardashian est une icône
je suis la reine d'angleterre qui a dit
ça s il avait la janis est ce quelqu'un
d'autre je dirait l'autre dans l'autre
ça peut-être
elizabeth 2
aujourd'hui de noël c'est
c'est pas vrai c'est isabelle adjani qui
analyse la
pièce parce qu'en vrai plat parce que
parce que tu me fais parler de trucs tu
m'a prévenu en plus de ça je savais pas
c'est le mien et j'ai répondu alors sais
même pas si c'est moi je n'ai pas pu
vérifier si cité de chez moi donc déjà
je me dis active entre elles
apparaissent pas parce que je veux pas
me sentir piégé en ce sens où je n'ai
pas les éléments de réponse alors on se
revoit pour
la piste je vais réfléchir